étranger tu n'es pas là nous ne sommes pas là
la voiture a explosé
viens chercher les filles je dois rester ici
avec Woodrow un autre chauffeur
souterrain père où es-tu
astéroïde City farm Route 6 Mile 75.
tes astronomes et Space Cadets
belle journée de commémoration de septembre  23e
3007 av. J.-C., lorsque la météorite des plaines arides a
eu un impact sur la Terre,
vous êtes très bon dans celui sur le
clochard dans le bordel qui obtient un
pédiatre amnésique, vous êtes très honnêtement peut-être
mon personnage préféré, je ne sais pas
pourquoi personne d'autre n'a aimé
quoi  est-ce que ces impulsions indiquent ce que oh
les bips et les blips nous ne connaissons pas certaines
de nos informations sur l'espace extra-atmosphérique Peut
ne plus être tout à fait exact de toute façon
il n'y a encore que neuf planètes dans le
système solaire pour autant que nous sachions Billy
sauf maintenant il y a un extraterrestre
je  je ne sais pas
je n'aime pas la façon dont ce gars
nous a regardés l'extraterrestre comment avait-il l'air d'être
condamnés
peut-être que nous le sommes je viens de naître le
président combien de temps peuvent-ils nous garder un
astéroïde ville légalement le monde  ne sera plus jamais
pareil c'est l'extraterrestre qui
devient nerveux c'est un extraterrestre à
Top Hat ce qu'il y a là-bas le sens de
la vie peut-être y en a-t-il un es-tu marié
je suis veuf mais ne dis pas à mes enfants que
tu dis que sa mère est morte  il
y a trois semaines voyons si elle est au paradis
ce qui n'existe pas pour moi bien sûr mais
tu es épiscopalienne dans ma solitude j'ai
appris à donner une foi complète et
inconditionnelle aux gens que j'aime
je ne sais pas si cela t'inclut mais ça
inclus ma fille et vos quatre
enfants parfois je pense que je me sens plus
à l'aise en dehors de l'atmosphère terrestre
oh wow
moi aussi ils sont étranges ne sont-ils pas des
enfants
par rapport aux gens normaux oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai ça
va si vite ça
va si vite
Je fais une scène de nu tu veux la voir ai-
je dit oui tu n'as rien dit je voulais
dire oui ma bouche ne parlait pas
[Musique]